in Rwanda sviyaga national park a small
caravan of researchers hauls precious
cargo through the forest
it's a three and a half year old
mountain gorilla named in booyah curry
poachers killed two members of her
family to capture her but were
themselves caught before they could sell
her on the black market now she's being
returned to the wild and if she's lucky
to rejoin her kind a gorilla can be
reintroduced in one of the group the
best choice
he is the group of origin unfortunately
for this case we didn't really have
enough information to know where was the
group there are dozens of gorilla groups
living here but there are fewer than 700
individual mountain gorillas left in all
of Africa
half of them live here in Rwanda the
other half live across the borders in
Uganda and Congo in all three countries
the gorillas are in peril the spread of
development and farming is slowly eating
away the gorillas territory
people here a poor so poaching is an
even more urgent problem in fact 10
guerrillas have been killed recently in
the worst spate of violence since the
1980s in many cases the poachers were
trying to snatch a baby gorilla to pick
one infant gorilla to go and try and
raise you must kill the whole family
because of gorillas are very protective
they won't allow their young to go so
it's a lot of destruction to just get
one infant which in all probability will
not survive
in Uganda Rangers are trying to beat the
odds they've joined forces with
government soldiers to patrol the park
hoping to make it safe for tourists as
well as the great apes when journalists
visit wing D National Park to see
gorillas in the wild teams of armed
guards come along for the journey and
make sure they survive the experience
tourism generates a lot of money which
is vital to gorilla conservation but
getting gorillas used to having humans
around can be a dangerous thing
in fact researcher Michelle goldsmith
says it makes the poachers job that much
easier eventually we'll have a forest
full of habituated animals and you leave
these animals who are now not fearful of
humans completely vulnerable to anyone
coming by
that's why Annie poaching patrols are so
vital just last November
Rangers stopped five armed poachers from
snatching a baby gorilla and they got
some help from a member of the gorillas
group there was this very loud prey and
it was a human cry and somebody was
asking I mean calling out for help
please I'm dying and I helped me save me
and actually it was one of the poachers
and who had got very close to one of the
gorillas and the gorilla had actually
attacked him on this occasion the
poachers were caught but there are more
out there
back in Rwanda the researchers find a
suitable group for in Fukui but she's
too scared to leave her human protectors
a few days later weakened by the stress
of her ordeal she dies more proof that
in these jungles were the last mountain
gorillas cling to existence nothing
comes easy
you